vingt-cinq mètres étaient venus de toute
la france et de divers pays d'europe
pour la deuxième rencontre
internationale de capoeira à elancourt
jugé par d'autres m que leurs
instructeurs habituel chacun participé
au stage afin de passer sa deuxième
troisième corps est facile de la
capoeira bhl se joue ce qu'on appelle
une roda et c'est travail conduit par de
la musique et cette musique qui a on va
dire propulsé l'énergie donc c'est pour
ça que vous avez une énergie qui émane
de ce chambre et qui donne envie
d'applaudir de chanter et d'accompagner
les calories ceux qui sont dans la rue
dans les figures totalement improvisée
nécessite l'écoutent de l'autre pour
éviter les coups pas besoin d'être
souple la souplesse s'acquiert au fil du
temps la maîtrise des acrobaties aussi
jusqu'au dépassement de soi c'est un
sport individuel mais aussi collective
parce que comme vous voyez au soudan 1
dans une rod et c'est le groupe qui
propulse l'énergie encore une fois
l'énergie les plus petits au monde à
revendre pour eux c'était un premier
batten une première fois réussi alors
commencer ça cette année on a ouvert nos
créneaux quatre en six ans et on a une
n 1 mondial berry sita dessus parce
qu'on n'a plus petits qui sont venus qui
sont super dynamique qui en veulent et
c'est encore mieux comme si cet âge est
parce qu ils sont complètement comme il
se plaît à quoi s'attendre il se lance à
corps perdu
l'association belo horizonte capoeira
compte aujourd'hui 70 adhérents de tous
âges